okay so for today's video we are gonna
discuss the greenhouse effect and
climate change so let's go ahead and get
started well so let's begin with what is
the greenhouse effect first of all the
greenhouse effect is incredibly vital to
the existence of life on Earth okay so
what is a greenhouse you know a
greenhouse is a glass building used to
trap heat to grow plants in cooler areas
in the picture here we have a greenhouse
it's trapping heat to keep the plants
that are inside nice and warm you know
pretend you're gonna go see a movie on a
weekend you drive in you park you get
out you go enjoy the show you come back
two hours later you know it's really hot
inside your car because the windows of
absorbed heat for this reason you would
never I hope leave your dog locked in a
car with the windows rolled up that
could very much be a fatal error so
let's now talk about the greenhouse
effect you know is there a glass
building that surrounds planet Earth of
course not but Earth has an atmosphere
that surrounds it that acts like a
greenhouse so the gases in Earth's
atmosphere trap heat to warm the earth
gases greenhouse gases such as carbon
dioxide greenhouse gases such as water
vapor and greenhouse gases such as
methane they trap heat in my animation
light from the Sun will reflect off the
surface of the earth as that happens
these greenhouse gases will absorb heat
near the surface of the earth to warm
the planet keeps earth nice and
comfortably warm you know the greenhouse
effect reminds me of Goldilocks and the
three bears you know one of the
porridges that shieff ate from was too
cold you know there's a planet in our
solar system that's too cold for life as
we know it because it doesn't have a
greenhouse effect Mars Mars has a very
thin atmosphere
very little heat is trapped and for the
most part it's a frozen planet it
doesn't really have a greenhouse effect
well this porridge is too hot there's a
planet in our solar system that is too
hot for life as we know it because it
has an extreme runaway greenhouse effect
I'm referring to planet Venus Venus has
a very thick carbon dioxide atmosphere a
lot of heat is trapped near the surface
of Venus and even though mercury is
closer to the Sun Venus is still the
hottest planet in the solar system
because of its extreme greenhouse effect
and then if we finish off our Goldilocks
analogy this porridge is just right
there's a planet in the solar system
that's just right for life and of course
I'm referring to Earth earth has a
life-giving atmosphere that traps just
enough heat so what's the problem why
are we having this discussion well the
problem is at the greenhouse effect the
natural greenhouse effect is out of
balance and that's what this video is
going to discuss so what do I mean by
the greenhouse effect is out of balance
well what I mean is the earth is getting
warmer you've probably heard of climate
change or you've probably heard of
global warming and so really it's out of
balance because of human actions you
know the burning of fossil fuels such as
coal oil natural gas these rule this
releases a lot of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere carbon dioxide is a
greenhouse gas
you know the burning of fossil fuels is
what provides energy for automobiles to
to be driven burning of fossil fuels
provides energy for industry to to
conduct their business burning of fossil
fuels powers homes to produce
electricity
you know agriculture has played a role
in the greenhouse effect being out of
balance
for instance the overuse of fertilizers
on farms releases a lot of nitrogen
oxides into the atmosphere nitrogen
oxides are a greenhouse
the overproduction of farm animals has
released a lot of methane into the
atmosphere again methane is a greenhouse
gas the deforestation of forests around
the world is contributing to the earth
getting warmer whether it's through
clear-cutting whether it's through
slash-and-burn techniques deforestation
removes photosynthetic plants that would
normally absorb carbon dioxide and
remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere remind viewers remember that
carbon dioxide is one of the the
reactants of photosynthesis plants will
absorb and remove carbon dioxide from
the environment in order to do
photosynthesis and let's not forget the
effects of water pollution in creating
an out-of-balance greenhouse effect you
know water pollution might runoff from
farms into rivers lakes streams and
eventually oceans
you know water pollution might runoff
from storm drains and sewage water
pollution you know from oil spills
perhaps and what we're seeing is a
pollution a polluted a polluted what
what we're seeing are polluted waterways
and as a result we're seeing the slow
death of photosynthetic algae just like
plants photosynthetic algae perform
photosynthesis so they to remove carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere so if we
come back to this animation before
here's again our natural greenhouse
effect a warm planet Earth but really
since the Industrial Revolution we've
been releasing a lot more of these
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
from the burning of fossil fuels from
the overuse of fertilizers from the
overproduction of farm animals and as a
result we have a really a thicker
atmosphere that is trapping even more
heat near the planet's surface and so
this is the this is the out of control
this is the man-made greenhouse of
this is climate change here so what are
some consequences of a warming planet
well some of the obvious ones you know
the melting of glaciers and polar ice
caps you know here's a picture of of the
northern polar area and in 1984 the
picture on the left 1984 versus the
picture on the right of 2012 you can see
a dramatic reduction in the northern
polar ice cap well all that water goes
into the ocean when it melts
thus rising sea levels you know here's a
picture of Venice Italy and if if you've
ever read or seen documentaries about
some of the difficulties that coastal
cities are having as a result of rising
sea levels
now Venice Italy is a great example of a
city that's having some incredibly
challenging problems now as a result of
rising sea levels you know another
consequence of a warming planet are more
severe weather storms and this is simply
because a warmer planet increases the
rate of water evaporation and eventually
water will evaporate at a faster pace
and then eventually what goes up must
come down well that might be good for
some areas that are receiving more
rainfall than normal but other areas are
receiving less rainfall because the
water is evaporating from certain areas
at a faster pace and the water
evaporates and then blows away through
the wind and and other areas may receive
more rainfall but other areas are more
prone to drought and one of the side
effects of drought would be a reduction
of crop production simply put if you're
trying to grow crops in an area that may
be in a drought that's gonna reduce the
crop yield and I think California is
first-hand witness to - the one - this
particular consequence
yet another consequence of a warming
planet is the spread of disease you know
for example here's the the mosquito that
causes malaria and it's larvae here the
mosquito is larva well I'm bringing up
this example because this particular
mosquito lives typically lives in a
warmer climate area and if the in
general if the earth Earth's climate is
becoming warmer you would expect this
mosquito to spread outward and kind of
take advantage of new habitats and
therefore a spread malaria to areas of
the world that aren't used to seeing the
final consequence I want to mention is
one called coral bleaching you know
here's a picture of a fairly healthy
coral reef here you know very colorful
lots of aquatic fish but here is an
example of coral that's been bleached
well with just a few degrees increase of
water temperature it causes the algae
that live inside of corals to die and
therefore the corals then die
and once the corals die then the habitat
starts the ecosystem excuse me starts to
fall apart and break down so we're
seeing reefs for instance coral reefs
begin to die around the world just
because of a few degree warmer
difference in ocean temperatures so what
is some of the science and the data
behind climate change and global warming
you know since the Industrial Revolution
the rate of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere has greatly increased
this graph shows it nicely far-right is
kind of current day and if you notice in
the middle of the graph it says for
650,000 years atmospheric carbon dioxide
has never been above this line at 300
parts per million until now so you see
current day we are way high on the
carbon dioxide parts per million that
are have that are accumulating in
Earth's atmosphere thus greatly
contributing
to climate change you know this graph
right here really shows nicely the
correlation between carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere and earth's temperature
the blue line represents atmospheric
carbon dioxide the red line represents
global average temperature and you can
see that as the blue line increases over
the years as the carbon dioxide
increases over the years so does the red
line so is the temperature now one year
the temperature might go up a little the
next year might drop a little the next
might go up the next year might go down
but the general pattern is as the blue
line increases so it is the red line
this shows a correlation between carbon
dioxide and temperature you know various
organizations have created computer
models and each one each model kind of
suggests the same thing the continual
warming of the earth now one model might
might suggest the earth will warm two
degrees over the next you know 100 200
300 years another model may say the
earth is gonna warm three degrees and
other will say four degrees but the
general pattern is that the of the
models is that they all indicate in hint
toward a continual warming of the earth
unless some very drastic actions are
taken so what do I mean by take action
well this is one of the situations that
is gonna require global cooperation you
know for instance just recently in 2015
the Paris agreement is an agreement
between nations of the world to pledge
to reduce their greenhouse gas emissions
well while this sounds wonderful the
nations really only did make a pledge to
reduce their greenhouse gas emissions
there's nothing legally binding there's
no legal consequences if a nation does
not meet its pledge but again it's a
step towards the right direction
you know around our home we could look
to reduce our use of fossil fuels for
instance certain vehicles have better
fuel efficiency than others and while a
hybrid or an electric vehicle doesn't
completely solve the problem it again
will help to lessen the effect you know
carpooling if we're gonna drive to work
or to school if we can team up with one
to three other individuals that way you
can you know reduce the amount of cars
that are on the road biking walking
distances not only saves fossil fuels
but also it's wonderful exercise
adjusting our heater in the winter
adjusting our air conditioner in the
summertime you know during the summer
time having the air conditioner a few
degrees higher than normal will save a
lot of electricity exploring alternative
energies you know certain cities or
states or even federal federal
government might give tax incentives if
you look in the solar power at your home
and let's not forget planting a tree
the act of reforestation trees again
remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere so the planting of more will
help to remove more carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere and the promotion of
organic farming organic farming does not
use any fertilizers and we mentioned
fertilizers contain nitrogen oxides
which is one of the greenhouse gases
responsible for climate change so there
you have it go ahead and pause this
video if you want to work on this quiz
and if you're in my class feel free to
write your answers on a separate sheet
of paper and I'd be happy to check your
answers either before school or after
school thank you